if you stand up against the liberal
ruling class you are going to be
vilified
that is guaranteed and you are going to
be called a racist why i don't know you
will and a sexist huh where does that
come from i don't know that's just what
they're going to call you they're going
to go so far as to call you a murderer
they're already doing that they're
saying if you don't do exactly what we
say even if our if our guidelines
contradict themselves one day to the
next if you don't do exactly what we say
you are a murderer you're responsible
for the epidemic you're responsible for
people dying this is what the cackling
hens on the view said just yesterday
about the new
spooky
omicron variant
they feel that their greater good is
more important than your greater good
well you know it was interesting to me
that the argument was being made if
you're vaccinated why do you care about
me being vaccinated you're protected and
that's why we are at the um
omarion omicron variant right that's why
we are where we are because it's
mutating it's becoming this crazy
superbug inside of the people that
aren't vaccinated and now it's affecting
us i don't know why they were not
understanding that we've got like 80
million people understand vaccinations
and they understand
they don't want to yeah here we all we
all
so first of all the cdc has already told
us that the vaccine does not totally
prevent you from contracting the virus
or transmitting the virus they told us
this at the end of july this is why the
vaccinated are still required to wear
masks even in lots
of different settings even after they've
received the vaccine this is why people
are receiving all of these boosters and
now we're being told in israel they're
contemplating requiring a fourth shot to
be fully vaccinated and there seems to
be no end in sight so spare me the
sanctimony there but furthermore let's
just take them at their word the
unvaccinated
are
causing or they're leading the the
cause
of the new variants
and their petria dishes and they're
creating all these new variants of covid
what we are told right now by the
scientists by all the geniuses
is that the new
omicron
is less
dangerous than the delta variant for
instance or the original
variant or some of the other flavors as
well
when viruses mutate
they generally speaking become
less dangerous
and these less dangerous strains can
become
the predominant strains
isn't that a good thing don't we want it
if you've got a relatively dangerous
variant and then it mutates and becomes
relatively less dangerous and then the
relatively less dangerous one becomes
the predominant strain
isn't that
better than letting the more dangerous
one be the predominant strain am i
am i stupid am i thick am i not reading
things correctly here's this from the
new york times i'm definitely going to
be stupid if i keep reading the new york
times the new york times headline
omicron is moving fast but perhaps less
severe
early reports
suggest
researchers in south africa where the
variant is spreading quickly say it may
cause less serious covid cases than
other forms of the virus but it's
unclear whether that will hold true
maybe that'll change over time that's
right as of now as of recording i don't
think anyone has died from omicron so
why is everybody freaking out
we should be happy that the virus is
becoming less and less severe as viruses
do that's just that's just what happens
that's why we're not living through the
spanish flu 1918 every single year
we're living through endemic sort of
seasonal flus that are not particularly
severe
hey you
hey hold on you don't know don't go
anywhere yet
it's nice to see you i'm glad you came
by this video and watched it if you want
to see more videos you got to subscribe
you got to ring that bell and even
beyond ringing the bell here which you
should do you got to go over to apple
podcasts spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast it
takes two seconds you pull out your
phone you type in the michael knowles
show subscribe maybe leave a five-star
review i don't know subscribe we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]